uh talk about the dvba approach a little
bit about its features not all can fit
in half an hour but i'll try to to to
make do
so first off uh
from
a vba at the beginning from office 95 97
there was like a a
a simple yes or no prompt to enable the
macros first off what
is explained there before
it's basically an event-based code that
runs at the background of office
documents okay we will see an example
for that later on
uh so at the beginning it was a simple
astronaut problem to enable macros you
can imagine how simple it was to
socially engineer the victim to just
click on that yes or no prompt to enable
the macros that of course caused the
macro via setup from 95 to 2003 well vba
micro based attack were pretty popular
and then in 2004 that all ended due to
microsoft policy change they basically
disabled macros by default making it
pretty hard to socially engineer the
victim to uh basically cause the
to to cause the victim to launch the
code
so that caused the vba winter when from
2004 to 2013 attackers preferred other
ways to attack the victims
then in 2014 everything changed again
and microsoft
basically decided to change their policy
and to add this enabled content that you
probably have seen uh all of you have
seen and all of you are familiar
basically a single enabled content after
seeing the document the document is
running in protected view and run in a
sandbox and probed in the sandbox but
the criminals have found a way to
bypass that this protected view so from
2014 to basically present day
vibe marcos came back again they're
usually
it uses a first stage to live
malware what i mean by first stage that
means that the vba macro basically just
downloads uh
downloads the the second stage of the
attack downloads and executable from
online for instance
okay so and once you download that
second stage attack from the web you can
basically do whatever you want that
ranges from banking trojans ransomwares
apts you name it
and recently microsoft changed its
policy again right
last month and basically what you can
see here
is the new prompt to enable macros
basically end users can still run macros
it just adds extra step so it remains to
be seen
what will happen next year regarding the
vba macro
vector
so as i said vba markos will use the
first first stage attack to deliver
malwares they're around 100 000
phishing emails per day that has some
sort of an attach attached to a
microsoft document
most vba macros has ever said
use social engineering to just make you
click on that content button once you
click on that content button that it's
too late the the code launches and
you're going to have a bad time
current antivirus engines are just not
enough there are too many macros every
day it's impossible to catch up with
signatures
and probably most
most malicious macros are not even
are not detected even if they are
several months old that means that a
signature free model is needed
uh basically solve this issue and that's
exactly where the vba comes in
so before i dive in into the
architecture and talk to you about deep
learning let's try to understand the
problem so if you manually analyze the
vba macro attack there are four
indicators that you want to look for in
the code okay so one of them is the code
has to be auto executable that means
that once the you social engineer the
victim to enable the content
there's no need to social engineer
social engineer the victim any further
okay
so the code just launches and we will
see an example for that in emertes
example which is a in famous vba macro
attack which i will present in this
presentation
secondly the second trigger that you
gotta look up to look out for is that
the uh the code it tries to download
an executable or maybe inject a code
into a process uh
that that this stage
basically symbolizes the
the attempt of the attacker to download
the second stage attack it tries to
download an executable from the web for
example
uh free
deferred the trigger
they also need to execute that payload
of course they don't necessarily do it
in immediately sometimes they schedule
it in like an um an office update or
something like that and they schedule it
for a later time because they want to
evade uh the probing
mechanism of the protective view of the
sandbox which tries to probe the
document and runs the code and tries to
see if something fishy happens
and
the fourth trigger which is uh really
really common is that they usually
off-circulate their code so for those
who do not know offsucation means that
they just scramble the code just
shift it around make it look really
really weird and we will see an example
for that later they usually do that to
hide their intent and make it hard for
analysts to understand
what the code is actually doing
so all these four triggers and you can
say that
a suspicious sample is one that it's a
it's auto executable has to run it
probably runs
automatically and it triggers one of the
uh other triggers
okay so let's let's get a little bit
more intimate with the issue so i'm
gonna present uh uh uh an in famous
example an infamous uh vba based macro
attack called emoted it was first
identified in 2014 as a backing malware
stealing a private information
and also note that it was in 2014 right
after microsoft changed its policies so
which is interesting to see
how microsoft policy changes affect the
the whole world
so uh it recently it's still active till
this day it was recently uh be used as a
service as an infrastructure as a
service for a delivering malware that
means that
criminals
buy that infrastructure to to
basically uh uh initiate their own
second stage attack
their own payload their own their own
criminal activity
so the most common
entry vector of ammo that is as i said
uh an attached a file that is usually
arrives at the victim through some spear
phishing email
now you can see here that uh it was
arguably
considered the world's most dangerous
malware
uh in january 2
21
that means for 2014 to january 21 it was
still an issue for the whole world and
it took all these states to to
collaborate in order to bring it down
and it's still active today as an
infrastructure as a service uh
it acts uh it has a free stage uh a
workflow
first it it is delivered to the victim's
computer via speci spear phishing email
the victim is then prompted to download
that file and basically just click on
enable content
once that happens the
computer becomes vulnerable and it will
and it and it can be offered for hire
for other criminals
and that fact makes it really really
hard to keep track of emoted once you
pass that an initial vector of attack
once once you click on enable content
it's really hard to stop that attack
because it because it can be anything
okay it can open doors for all kinds of
attack
from
information stealers trojans ransomware
and many many more
so just a general note
not regarding this presentation just how
to protect yourself from these kind of
things
so if you receive an email from an anno
sender with some sort of attachment be
wary of it especially if it has a sense
of an urgency or maybe it offers you a
million bucks that that doesn't make any
sense so please don't download attached
file from strangers
so here's a real life example of how
animated text looks like so this is the
spear phishing email the the very first
time you encounter the demo that in the
wild you receive an attachment you
receive an email in your outlook account
of your organization and it tells you oh
you have to pay something never mind
what it is you just have to pay it you
just have it right now
a sense of urgency indeed
uh once the victim
he just downlinks enable content right
away
and once he enables that the content the
code launches now that's where we dive
in that's where that's what we're
interested about we're interested about
analyzing the source code and not
analyzing the document and the email
vba just looks at the code itself and on
first view it looks kind of hard
what is happening here okay this this is
really emitted it's a code a small part
of it uh talked about observation for
those who do not know that's how
observation looks like just look at the
code and you don't know what's happening
that's when you know you you you have
observation
uh
so the code is highly observated and we
want and we're manually analyzing this
code so we have to search for those four
triggers so i made it easy for you
already search for them uh so you can
see that the document open which is an
event-based as i said vba is an
event-based code language and document
open these api calls which are
event-based cannot be obstricated okay
so here you go you can see here that the
code is auto executable and the
observation signal is plain to see
so after a cumbersome manual analysis
i i won't do it right here i'd done it
before
the code basically what it does
you can see here it launches a
powershell process
that later on
it downloads an executable and launches
it okay so that's
all the four triggers right there
but you can see that we had to manually
deosecate this code in order to get
these triggers right
so how how do we catch that signal
without de-obstructing the code we will
get to that later how dba does that
so just to just to get the idea of the
the of the australian
level here you can see here the line of
code which was initially the observated
code and after a lot of de-observation
effort it was transformed into this
which basically just zooms in if you
once i zoomed in into what really
happens here you can see that it's
running a powershell and then
just runs a code that downloads
something from online and actually then
executes it and
but when this code launches it's already
too late
i just wanna uh uh i want you to
remember this get object okay these get
object uh
api calls cannot cannot be offsucated
and i just want you to remember that i
will get into that i will get back to
the in the following
slides
okay i already talked about this
okay just to summarize before we
continue to the vba approach
the initial vector of the attack is the
vba marco which is attached to uh
malicious documents
in this instance the vba macro wants a
powershell process that downloads an
execute an executable called whatever it
could be anything the second stage
attack can be pretty much anything
think about it as an open source library
for criminals okay
uh
eventually what this actually in in this
particular case the executable opens the
back door and then criminals can install
whatever they want they basically on
your computer
so how does current approaches try to
detect the vpa uh macros based on the
code itself okay we're just trying to
look at the code and understand what
what's happening so most attempts try to
use some handcrafted features or maybe
handpick words combined with some sort
of basic classifiers
but
other than the those features are hand
crafted and cause a bias into your model
into your solution they also have a big
disadvantage which is which is that the
features are computed on the code as one
single chunk
and i remind you when i showed you demo
that's example all that code is one
single chunk it was pretty it's really
hard to understand what's happening
pretty it's really hard to understand
what is the initial entry point
uh and moreover a lot of attackers
evasive maneuvers where they just add
meaningless functions to event detection
so you can think about if you look at
the code as one single chunk
you're going to have a bad time
it's really hard to to understand what's
happening and it's as
a significant amount of noise and that's
exactly what the vba
tries to to to solve basically aims to
identify these four suspicious triggers
while overcoming non-evasive maneuvers
minimizing the noise in the input
being a signature free model and also a
lightweight model
okay so that means you can't just throw
gpt free on it it won't it's not it's it
won't work because eventually
this
project needs to
basically work on each and on every
document that you receive
through email okay
so uh what the vba does is basically it
utilizes the core graph structure and
the vba macro code itself which
functions separately and then
jointly
and tries to identify the vba markup as
malicious or benign now let's see what i
mean so dvba uses an open source library
called vba to graph which was developed
here at checkpoint by our very own
security expert mikhail abramson a vba
to graph it creates a call graph from
the vba macro and you can see it here
this is amazon's example
after i ran a vba to graph on it and you
can see it's a lot easier to see it like
this you can see the document open this
the initial entry point all these red
frames is kind of hard to see from the
presentation but that means that this uh
graph this this connected graph there
could be other disconnected graphs but
in this case there's uh there is only
three functions and you can see that all
of this graph is auto executable
and also
what vba does
is also a marks some suspicious keywords
and api calls and
remember when i told you to remember
that get object so here it is that get
object it wasn't in the initial it
wasn't in the offset line of code but it
was somewhere else okay so and all these
other c bytes and all these chart w's
are usually used as attempts to
authenticate your code
okay
so what you can see here is basically
that the attacker just from the get go
just from this feature just from the
keyword sequence right here you can
already understand that i have enough
circaded signal
i have an auto executable signal
and i also have something he tries to
initialize some sort of object and do
something that it tries to hide its
intent so that's already a good feature
that helps us extract these signals
so let's talk about the deep vba
architecture just the overview we'll get
back into
each single model
try to talk about don't have enough time
but i'll try to make do
so at the beginning we have we have a
call graph and the number of features
for each function is different okay and
i need to bring it into a fixed size
representation in order to aggregate the
node the nodes together okay so how do
we do that we basically use a module
called node embedding the node embedding
is run
over all the nodes in parallel and
outputs a single
a fixed vector a representation
there
in the next slide we'll talk about a
really cool feature that we are using
other than the keyword sequence
in the node embedding
after we have a fixed size
representation for each function we can
run it through a graph neural network
approach which is basically
like a convolutional layer only that the
spatial filter here is not the
neighboring pixels is the neighboring
nodes
okay
so after the graph neural network we
still have a call we still have a a
graph presentation and remember this
call graph we eventually wants to we
eventually want to have a malicious
score okay so this is a graph to one
architecture so we use an attention
layer that has a cool side effect that
emphasizes suspicious functions
uh
to basically clamp it down into a single
graph embedding that graphing bending is
then fed into a few linear layers to
output the malicious score
okay so let's talk a little bit about a
node embedding
okay so the node embedding it receives
all the uh
all the all the features of the of the
function you see in one of them was the
keyword sequence it has also the auto
executable which node is auto executable
and it has two other features that i
will discuss in the next two slides and
that is the code token sequence
basically what we're doing is we're
trying to identify the observation
signal but not only okay so how do we do
that uh we use a
byte pairing coding tokenizer or bpe
tokenizer and we use it and we train it
on our database of course and remember
that our usually
the database for
the cyber domain is unbalanced you
pretty much have 95 99 benign and one
percent malicious okay
so when you train it on on our data it
kind of acts similar to huffman
compression we will see what i mean okay
so uh basically most as i said before
most malicious examples are offsucated
so obstacle will be harder to compress
and that's because the
tokenizer the bpe tokenizer is merge
rule is based on frequent words and you
can imagine that that this
long ass word is not frequent in our
data okay it's generated it's randomized
so here you can see like an example i
just fished out a random malicious
sample from our database and then i ran
our train tokenizer on that
function and you can see
that it's made up of specific tokens and
those tokens are the base tokens okay
it's not comprised of the call or the ad
or the ad which are frequent words most
of it is is the base vocab
based vocab tokens and we will see how
different
the distribution over the tokens in the
next two slides
uh just to clarify the x's and the v is
our special token uh the x's symbolizes
a number sequence we're not interested
to learn which number it is we're just
interested to know that was there was a
lot of
english letters and then some random
numbers that's what that's how we try to
extract that oxidation signal
uh and the v is just mark a line drop
you can see that a new line has begun
okay so here i talked about the
compression i talked about huffman
compression what does that have to do
with the tokenizer itself so here we can
see the distribution between the benign
and the malicious compression ratio that
means that i took the number of tokens
that symbolizes a function and i divided
it by the length of the of the string
and you can see that as we assumed the
compression ratio for the midnight will
be a lot better that means that we
managed to compress benign sample to 25
percent of the original side well the
mean
well the mean for the malicious samples
was 35 of their initial size that means
that it's harder to compress of
circulated signals okay
so that's that's the compression ratio
which is just a scalar is also one of
our most significant features and you
can see this overlap right here and this
overlap is exactly those evasive
maneuvers that i talked about they just
add benign functions that look
seamlessly uh
innocent but basically some other part
of the graph is doing the malicious work
okay so here you can see the
wide difference between the benign token
cloud and the malicious token cloud and
you can see as i said malicious tokens
mostly made of base vocab characters but
what i mean by base vocab characters is
the b as the e s the c is the f
uh where the benign token cloud is made
up of frequent english words that we all
that we are familiar with
so i talked about the node demanding
model
there's a little bit more features to it
it's a bit more complicated than that
but i won't get into into it
so after the node embedding basically
ran on our call graph we have now a
fixed size representation for each
function
and we want to now we have an embedding
for each for each node separately but we
still want to aggregate the information
between the nodes because the document
opened in emoted case called the second
function but the the so far they haven't
exchanged information between the
between the nodes
so what we have is a graph neural
network that basically acts as a special
kind of convolution as i said it
aggregates information between
neighboring nodes
and what we use in our current
architecture
is a layer called a graph convolutional
layer and you can see
the message passing here message passing
by the way is a mechanism that a graph
neural network used to aggregate
neighboring nodes and this particular
case the equation looks like this
basically you have the theta a weight
matrix and a eye is the focal point is
the central it's the central pixel if i
use the analogy to convolutional layer
ni is the neighboring pixels okay the
neighboring nodes in this instance and k
is just the the index of the layer in
the whole architecture
and you can see here that we also divide
the
each node embedding when we aggregate it
we divide we normalize it by the degree
of the node okay
so after the graph neural network we
still have a graph and we still want to
compress it
to get a graph embedding
so we use an attention layer
so the attention layer what it basically
does it outputs a probability
distribution over the node
and then we use that and we use that
probability distribution
uh in order to do a weighted average uh
over the nodes to get a single graph
embedding and there's this and there's a
cool feature to it is that the the
probability distribution as you can see
here i just ran my i ran our model on
the imototuts example
it of course detected it as malicious
and also he decided to give uniform
uniform
distribution over the malicious nodes
that's because all of the nodes are
malicious but what will happen if i will
add benign functions to it
let's see
so i added some benign functions that i
wrote myself okay basically just
orders around the column in excel pretty
benign nothing suspicious about it
and then i ran all i run it as one
single function as one single as one
single sample and you can see here that
still the model uh uh uh
learned he basically learned the
attention layer gave more weight
to the malicious
nodes which were in this case the emotex
functions and gave smaller weights to
the benign function so that's a cool way
of us to also augment our data we can
then later on use benign functions to
augment our data and then enrich our
malicious
database
and also it adds to explainability
that's a cool feature
so
we reached the summary
with even a five minutes to spare so
more time for questions
uh
so at the beginning you have a spear
phishing email you download the document
and then
you're prompted to click on enable
content once you do that the code
launches okay so before the victim
receives the email
in in checkpoints in one of checkpoints
engines we basically extract the code
before it reaches your your computer and
we take this code the string of code and
we use vba to graph to to create this
call graph you see here and then we feed
it into the vba to get a malicious score
okay and that's one of the features that
we're uh
using a checkpoint to protect your
computers from attached uh malicious
documents
okay so that's it thank you and there's
also five minutes to spare so if you got
any questions i'll be happy to hear them
yes if you are using the graph why don't
you run the vba on the way to connect
the power
but not the whole crop
[Music]
uh you mean what do you mean by weekly
connected you mean the oh you mean
though
yes
[Music]
yeah well it's it's an interesting
thought we haven't tried it yet
uh
i can tell you that the variance here is
pretty large okay each each malicious uh
looks different it's just benign sample
looks different and we try to extract
the information for the code itself
okay so what if i understood your
question
you basically said uh you have those
weaker components
a part in your graph basically
unrelated to one another well i i can
tell you you can't really know that okay
because you can have the
we had the document open right here
which was the uh the amortets but there
also was an executable and not
executable functions that was the auto
on the workbook open okay so
maybe that was the benign and that was
the malicious you can't really know yeah
but
what i meant
if you separate into anti-connected
components you can say that this
component is malicious and this
component
is benign
so
it will
and we'll look into it in our research
of course this is a project that we run
uh like seven months
four months
five months
uh so there's a lot more to research and
i like that idea to look at the weekly
point we haven't yet actually looked at
the graph
properties of each
sample we just tried to extract the best
node embedding we can from each node but
the graph structure also has valuable
information we haven't even scratched
the surface in that regards but it's an
interesting idea
yes you said lightweight so how much
pre-processing time it takes to actually
extract that graph and then run it like
how likely does it eventually is like
eventually we're aiming to hundreds of
milliseconds that's our aim
uh the whole pipeline of course the
input is variable length okay because
you can you can have graphs of two
functions you can have graphs of 500
5000 functions and it's interesting to
ask how do you truncate your input right
now because you maybe you truncate the
malicious part just remember the benign
part
so it's a pretty interesting question
how to truncate the the graph
just
ballpark how how bad how good is it now
so the variance here is pretty it's if
you take all these if you don't put a
limit then you can reach even 10 seconds
in current practical use
hundreds of milliseconds right
yes that's that's the mean okay but
there is a
you're still researching how to prevent
something like a ddos attack by using
big
big data it's like because you told me
that graph can be big yeah the graph can
be pretty large
so we're still recently researching how
to basically truncate it and still
maintain the
demolition to not
accidentally delete the malicious nodes
uh
currently we just
we're still
tackling this this issue of the really
really large graphs
i would say the civil line here is that
it's
the micro percentage of our data those
really really large graphs so it's not
it's not it's it's interesting it's not
that interesting as a statistically
interesting because most of the most of
the samples you know if you get an
attached document with
thousands of
functions the document will be pretty
large
uh
so
also it's it's it's statistically uh
you can ignore it for now so you're
thinking about how to scale it up
basically of course it's uh it's it's
one of our questions to ask how to
truncate that day how to truncate really
large graphs
no problem
because
it seems that
and you're not embedding you you made a
separation not between the vicious and
benign at least the level that you talk
about but uh between obfuscated and non
obfuscated codes so aren't there like
benign vba script which are obfuscated
and there will be
it's not a binary classification but it
will get the same embedding as uh you
know as a malicious script and get uh
that's a very good question
uh because you know we try to aim we try
to identify that oxidation signal and we
say it's one of our triggers but indeed
a benign sample can also be observated
but it's not it's 99 of the times it's
not the case and if it is then it should
be uh you know uh uh
detained at the border so to speak for
further analysis
okay
so yeah
yes we are currently uh around the i
won't tell you all the data all these
metrics because we just don't have
enough time to discuss it and also
it's not that plain and simple what the
poc objective was which we passed was
around 95 precision and 40 40 recall now
remember that we're aiming where
our our reference verdict is one that
was computed over dynamic analysis that
means that someone actually run that
code looked at the document looked at
the email had that all information and
then made a decision so reaching 40
percent a recall only on the code itself
is a pretty a good feat
to my opinion at least
yes way back there
oh so uh jacob here asked that question
the latency so i i'm sorry
i'll repeat the q i'll repeat the answer
the mean
the mean area for the latency is
hundreds of microseconds of course
there's a lot of optimizations that can
be done okay we this is still just past
poc so there's a lot and a lot of
optimization that you can do but the
model itself is pretty small it's around
five megabytes
okay and it can also be smaller
yes it also includes pre-processing of
course as i said the input is variable
length so if you get a huge
a huge sample then of course it will
take a lot more than 100 uh milliseconds
and then hundreds of milliseconds
uh but that's not the case
and 99 of the times okay so back there
yeah so the attention mechanism right
now is a simple mechanism it can be
better it can be
improved but the idea is to use the idea
of using the attention layer to
aggregate uh a lot of vectors to create
one single embedding is not a new idea
uh so i just used it
and sometimes it it acts as uh as a
explainability mechanism but currently
i'm just using an iraqial attention
mechanism
in the future i would like to maybe try
self-attention a transformal
layer
but it remains to be seen
thank you thank you for listening had a
great time
you